als sleepy Joe als schläfriger Joe von
Donald Trump im Wahlkampf verhöhnt wurde
Joe Biden trotzdem vor einem Jahr als 46
der Präsident der USA vereidigt mit
Vorschusslorbeeren gestartet und am
Anfang mit politischer Fortin der
inzwischen 79-Jährige das Versprechen
auf ein besseres Amerika einzulösen das
würde heute kaum jemand mehr
uneingeschränkt behaupten eine
enttäuschende Bilanz ein Jahr zu beiden
jetzt in der Phönix Runde
[Musik]
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
zunächst hier im Studio ist Katrin
klüger eschbrook sie sind Direktorin der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik die
gapulirien ist Leiterin des Berliner
Berliner Büros des European Council on
for Rain relations of gut deutsch ein
Pan europäisches Netzwerk für
internationale Beziehungen und
zugeschaltet aus Washington Ines Pohl
die Leiterin des Studiums der Deutschen
Welle in der amerikanischen Hauptstadt
und ebenfalls aus Washington Peter rau
sie sind am herzeninstitute in
Washington DC sie sind das gehört hier
auch noch dazu und zum Thema auch
Mitglied der republikanischen Partei der
USA in das Pole die Pressekonferenz von
Joe Biden diese Woche zum einjährigen
Amtsjubiläum die war ja eigentlich als
aufbruchssignal gedacht aber es war doch
eine ziemlich durchwachsene Sache
ja er ist wirklich stark unter Beschuss
aus allen möglichen Ecken zum einen sind
die Umfragewerte wirklich furchtbar
schlecht 65 Prozent der Amerikanerinnen
und Amerikaner denken dass seine
Präsidentschaft sozusagen schon jetzt am
Ende ist er hat große Probleme seine
eigene Partei zu vereinen er wird durch
die Republikaner blockiert und hat jetzt
dem Kurven 19 auch noch das große
Problem der Russen Russland nahe an der
Grenze zu Ukraine und das war gestern
auch bei der Pressekonferenz deutlich
spürbar das ist unglaublich viel ist
wozu er sich äußern muss und er ist
manchmal rhetorisch nicht so richtig
glücklich und hat ein paar Aussetzer vor
allen Dingen was die Strategie gegenüber
Russland anbelangt also das war alles
andere als ein gelungener Auftritt und
das Weiße Haus musste sofort
nachjustieren und ein missverständliches
eine missverständliche Äußerungen
bereinigen die nämlich sagte dass du ein
kleiner Einmarsch von Russland
wahrscheinlich ist aber dass die USA
darauf nicht reagieren würden also das
Gegenteil von dem was sehr
wahrscheinlich seine Unterstützerinnen
und Unterstützer sich erhofft hatten
also nicht ganz so ein glücklicher
Auftritt rhetorisch auch nicht so
beschlagen man musste nachjustieren
Peter rau da können ja die Republikaner
in den USA ihr Glück kaum fassen bei
einem solchen Präsidenten aber ist es
wirklich für die USA insgesamt so
bekömmlich für die gesamte für das
gesamte Land wenn nach den
Kongresswahlen im Herbst einen politisch
impotenter Präsident im Waisenhaus sitzt
das ist ja eigentlich die Absicht die
Republikaner hegen aber hilft das
wirklich den USA insgesamt damit auch
der republikanischen Partei
das ist ja eine Annahme man denkt die
zurück an die mitte 90er Jahren da
könnten wir tief angeschlagen er hat
1994 eine große Niederlage einfahren
müssen hat die Kontrolle über den
Kongress nach Jahrzehnten verloren und
danach hat er sich messen müssen es in
die politische Mitte gekehrt und hat
dadurch mit den republikan wenn eine
gemeinsame Politik machen hat auch die
Wiederwahl gewonnen gegen
1996 zwei Jahre später also es stimmt
das Jovan in einen tiefsturz also in
einen Tiefflug im Moment sitzt aber man
kann versuchen nach den Kongresswahlen
eine Neuanfang zu machen und das Paradox
ist ja wenn Job beim die Stichwahlen in
Georgia letzten Jahr nach vor einem Jahr
verloren hätte dann müsste er mit den
Republikanern korreliert man hätte
vielleicht eine gemäßigte Politik der
Mitte anstattung versucht die USA in
einer Sozialdemokratie und zu färben und
was bei den Wählern anscheinend nicht
ankommt
einen solchen Sturzflug in Umfragen und
Sympathie werten den hat man noch selten
erlebt wer hat denn daran neben Joe
beiden selbst eigentlich den Hauptanteil
seine Beraterinnen und Berater oder
seine ziemlich irrlichternde Partei ja
Joe Beine würde sagen es liegt daran
dass er sich selber eine so
ambitionierte Agenda gesetzt hat dass er
vielleicht damit so nicht hätte
durchkommen können also das hatte das
hat Frau Pohl gerade schon angesprochen
so hat es zumindest gestern in der
Pressekonferenz gesagt aber es ist mit
Sicherheit so und das haben wir
Analysten vorher erwartet vorausgesagt
das ist ja schwierig sein würde seine
großpartei die Demokraten sind jetzt
wirklich einem Partei die teilweise am
sehr konservativen Rand spielt und da
sind zwei Senatoren die eben gerade
wirklich das Leben schwer machen und im
zwischen am sehr sehr linksliberalen der
Teil der Partei auch sich aufstellt das
heißt es kommt jetzt schon es klingt
jetzt langsam an die Zerreißprobe
innerhalb der Demokratischen Partei die
wir alle vorausgesagt haben also selbst
dann wenn er sich jetzt noch Freiräume
freischaufeln könnte und Amerika ist für
das wieder aufstehen bekannt wird es
sehr sehr schwierig werden sagen dass
zum Beispiel bei SPD und CDU im
Vergleich dazu gibt es ja auch sehr
ausgeprägte Flügel ist die Demokratische
Partei der USA viel überdehnter ja die
Demokratische Partei der USA sind die
SPD und die CDU also die sind im Grunde
genommen eine große Koalition mit den
entsprechenden Randgruppen an jeder
Seite und weil Peter Haus gesagt die
Mehrheiten denkbar so dünn sind geht es
wirklich um jede einzelne Person und das
infrastrukturpaket was er durchbekommen
hat dieser Präsident das ist inzwischen
das infrastrukturpaket von einem Mann
nämlich von Joe Mansion dem am rechten
Rand einzuordnen demokratischen Senator
aus West Virginia von einem Jahr gab es
ja ein Aufatmen in Europa nach dem
Wahlsieg von Joe Biden jetzt scheint ja
bei vielen so der Schrecken
zurückgekommen zu sein beginnt das große
Zittern vor dem Herbst 2024 hier in
Europa dem nächsten Wahltermin für die
US-Präsidentschaft also ich glaube Joe
Biden ist erstmal mit sehr viel
Vorschusslorbeeren hier in Europa
gestartet die Europäer waren froh und
glücklich dass er die Wahl gewonnen
hatte und Joe Biden hat am Anfang alles
richtig gemacht er hat versucht im
Handelsstreit zwischen Airbus und Boeing
zum Beispiel gab es Einigungen nach
langen Jahren er hat nicht wie Donald
Trump gesagt er zieht Soldaten aus
Deutschland ab er hat mehr geschickt er
hat einen Arrangement mit der
Bundesregierung zur nordstream 2
Pipeline gefunden hat ganz viele Signale
gesendet Amerika ist zurück die
internationalen Organisation sind wieder
wichtig und dann kam sozusagen der Bruch
aus europäischer Sicht durch Afghanistan
und den Deal mit Australien und
Großbritannien über die Köpfe der
Franzosen hinweg wenn es um die U-Boote
ging vom vom letzten Jahr und das war
wie so ein Kälteschock für die Europäer
die dann gedacht haben
sieht gar nicht so anders aus als es
vorher war und vielleicht ist der
Unterschied zwischen den beiden und
Trump gar nicht so groß und man hat
große Sorge dass 2024 jetzt also jetzt
erst bei den mütterns und dann 2024 eben
wieder ein republikanischer Präsident
vom Stil Donald Trumps ins ankommen
könnte in Deutschland ein sehr unfeines
Sprichwort dass man mit dem Hintern
einreißt was man sich mühsam aufgebaut
hat würde das dazu treffen Bezug auf
weitens Politik also jedenfalls diesen
Bruch den sie gerade geschildert haben
ich glaube der Bruch war unglücklich der
Afghanistan Abzug war schlecht
kommuniziert mit den europäischen
Verbündeten auch mit Frankreich hat man
es sich ziemlich verscherzt
aber transatlantische
Meinungsverschiedenheiten sind ja nichts
Ungewöhnliches wir neigen im Rückblick
immer dazu die transatlantischen
Beziehungen zu romantisieren das früher
alles so viel besser war ich glaube halt
nur dass nach den trump-jahren die
Erwartung an beiden ebenso groß war und
an diese Nachricht Amerika ist wieder da
beiden hat es ja auch sehr stark gemacht
dass ja das ist für die also für die für
die Europäer sehr schwer war die
Amerikaner zu lesen wir haben so unser
Gefühl verloren
unseren Alliierten unseren Ängsten
Alliierten einzuschätzen und wissen auch
nicht was innenpolitisch in den USA
passiert und es gibt glaube ich eine
ganz große Unsicherheit in Europa wie
Amerika zu lesen ist dieser Tage Frau
Pohl es gibt ja im in der Politik immer
das Bedürfnis so knackige claims zu
machen Slogans könnte man sagen ein Jahr
Joe Biden gut gemeint aber schlecht
geplant
würde ich so nicht sagen er hat es wurde
gerade auch schon angesprochen dieses
eine billionstarke infrastrukturpaket
durchbekommen ist haben Präsidenten über
60 Jahre hinweg versucht es ist ihnen
nicht gelungen pech für beide dass die
Lorbeeren sozusagen oder die positive
Auswirkungen erstmal nicht zu spüren
sind deswegen wird sich das für ihn kaum
auszahlen bei den kommenden Wahlen aber
ich bin sicher wenn wir zurückschauen
sehr wahrscheinlich nicht diese Runde
aber in 30 40 Jahren und in die
Geschichtsbücher blicken wird es als
eine ganz herausragende Leistung
gewürdigt werden das Problem ist ja
Donald Trump ist weg Joe Biden ist da
aber Amerika hat sich ja nicht verändert
und ich glaube das war eine Grund ein
Fehler in der Grundannahme vieler
europäische Länder und auch viele
deutscher und deutsche Politikerinnen
und Politiker dass sich das Land deshalb
ja nicht verändert nur weil in neuer
Präsident im Weißen Haus sitzt wir
müssen uns immer wieder vergegenwärtigen
dass es nur 70.000 Stimmen waren 70.000
stimmen
in meinem Land was über 350 Millionen
Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner hat die am
Ende entschieden haben dass Joe Biden in
zwei sehr House einzieht und Donald
Trump auszieht warum das hängt mit dem
spezifischen
wahlrechtssystem hier in den USA
zusammen was sie sagen will die
Entscheidung war wirklich knapp und
deshalb sind auch deshalb sind Joe Biden
die Hände gebunden wir haben es
angesprochen er hat in politisch nur
knappe Mehrheiten aber auch die
Bevölkerung steht einfach nicht so
mehrheitlich hinter seiner Agenda wie er
sich das sicher wünschen würde das Land
ist ja ganz offensichtlich auch ziemlich
gespalten heraus wenn man mal die
Habenseite von Joe Biden ansieht Ines
Pool hat gerade schon gesagt dieses
infrastrukturpaket das sind ja ungefähr
eine Billion US-Dollar in die Hand
genommen worden wenn man sich die das
wissen sie besser als wir hier die
Straßen Brücken und die Infrastruktur an
sie den USA dringend nötig da hat man
schon lange versucht etwas zu machen er
hat es jetzt umgesetzt er hat die
doppelte Summe also fast zwei Billionen
in ein corona-hilfspaket gesteckt was ja
auch wichtig war denn auch die
amerikanischen Bürger sind ja von Corona
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sind ja
mitgenommen worden um das aufzufangen
was Corona möglicherweise an sozialen
Schäden anrichtet das steht ja auf
seiner hartenseite hat er das zu
schlecht kommuniziert was er für die
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner da getan
hat
das wäre sicherlich das Argument von Joe
Biden das ist ein Kommunikation fehlt
ein Gegenargument wäre dass wir letztes
Jahr im Herbst drei große Pakete
überparteilich verabschieden haben
können dieses Jahr gab es nur eines und
das war parteipolitisch drei mit
demokratischer Partei Stimme
verabschiedet darüber hinaus haben wir
die Gelder die letzten Herbst vom
Parlament genehmigt worden sind noch
nicht mal ausgegeben da kam schon das
nächste Paket und dann kam das große
Infrastrukturprojekt jetzt gibt es eine
teurerung und manche Amerikaner tragen
Sorge so gibt sich auch in den Umfragen
das kann man von der nomosomen abnehmen
dass man hier viel Geld ausgibt die
Teuerung kommt die Inflation und dass
man vielleicht etwas zurückstecken soll
ist natürlich ein Problem für Joe bin
denn seine restlichen großen Anliegen
bedeuten sehr viel Geld auszugeben wenn
es achtens nach ist Joe Biden jemand der
ins Amt gewählt worden ist um Normalität
wieder zurückzubringen und mit Job
beiden ist Normalität gekommen nach den
Recht möbelhaften der Donald Trump und
nach der letzten vier Jahren aber er hat
sich einfach verrechnet weil er globalen
Fehler begangen hat seinen Wahlsiegs war
eigentlich würde ich sagen eine
Niederlage von Donald Trump sowie auch
das party-senat wo man 50 Demokraten und
fühlt sich republikanische Senatorin hat
und im Unterhaus im Abgeordnetenhaus für
die Demokraten die kleinste Mehrheit und
den jahrhundert haben als wenn man da
den teleportiert um das völlig zu
verändern und große Reformen auf dem Weg
zu bringen Normalisierung ja die Creme
zu wenig überwinden das auch aber
vielleicht nicht mehr und ich glaube
gerade deswegen hat er sich so schwer
getan und ist er in den Umfragen so
abgesunken sehr vorgeprescht wenn das
bei so knappen Mehrheiten zu sagen also
da geht ja knapp die Hälfte dann gar
nicht mit wenn ich das jetzt umsetze es
geht ja um das was Peter row vorhin als
Sozialdemokratisierung der USA genannt
hat also eine
üppige Ausgabenpolitik wir reden noch
über ein anderes Paket kommt gleich noch
dass er weniger Chancen hat durchzugehen
ist das ist er dazu zu forsch
vorgegangen das würde er selber von sich
auch sagen er hat auch gesagt er müsste
mehr ins Land gehen und das entsprechend
verkaufen denn
die Vorredner schon angekündigt haben
sind die großpakete die ihr
durchgebracht hat Dinge die sich nicht
sofort fühlen lassen für den Amerikaner
was fühlen die Amerikaner die fühlen
sehr wohl die Inflation die fühlen sehr
wohl die Preise an den Tankstellen die
fühlen sehr wohl das vielleicht 166
Dollar Ausgleich für die Kinderbetreuung
die jetzt sehr wohl auf den
amerikanischen Konten angekommen sind
vielleicht auch ein bisschen wenig Sinn
für das was amerikanische Eltern haben
jetzt seit fast drei Jahren ausbaden
müssen und er hat sich natürlich
aufgeschwungen einen sozialreformspaket
zu machen was in in die Riege hätte
packen sollen von Roosevelt und LB J und
das hat er auch so gesagt und das heißt
da war natürlich der Johnson da war
natürlich die Ansprüche auch hoch das
heißt die Demokraten haben geguckt sie
wollen so wollten so viel wie möglich
durchbringen also lindenbie Johnson der
Präsident der nach Kennedy kam nicht
dass jemand denkt wir reden von Boris
Johnson nein wir reden von dem
Präsidenten der im Grunde genommen die
bürgerrechtsreform auf dem Weg und die
Wahlrechtsreform auf den Weg gebracht
haben die jetzt natürlich und wir
sprechen dann noch später drüber mit
Sicherheit die jetzt auch der Präsident
durchsetzen möchte weil er natürlich das
Land beschützen möchte so würde er das
Sagen vor dem Raubbau den die
Republikaner weiter an der
amerikanischen Demokratie betreiben wir
haben jetzt gerade von der Habenseite
gesprochen was er eigentlich umgesetzt
hat und was auch für ihn spricht es gibt
auch eine Sollseite er bekommt die
Pandemie nicht in den Griff obwohl das
möglicherweise ein wichtiger Grund war
ihm zu wählen da hat ja Donald Trump
nicht besonders erfolgreich agiert aber
schon beiden tut es auch nicht die
Inflation ist bei 7% in USA das muss
nicht unbedingt das Verschulden von Joe
Biden sein aber die Ausgabenprogramme
haben natürlich die Wirtschaft erstens
angeheizt die Preise steigen lassen
Lieferketten unterbrochen wie in
Deutschland auch Rohstoffe gehen durch
die Decke was die Preise angeht und es
gab einen erbärmlichen Abzug aus
Afghanistan im letzten August
wo bleibt da eigentlich die viel
gepriesene Erfahrung und Kompetenz von
Joe Biden der 35 Jahre lang steht im
Kongress war und auch noch Vizepräsident
das ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt der
gestern auch wieder in der
Pressekonferenz kam er sagt er habe viel
zu viel in Hinterzimmern verhandelt um
die gesetzesprogramme auf den Weg zu
bringen und viel zu wenig kommuniziert
mit dem mit der amerikanischen
Bevölkerung das da gibt es mit jedem in
jedem Fall ein Wahrnehmungsproblem aber
er hat sich nicht richtig eingeteilt wie
diese Verhandlungen zu laufen haben und
das ist glaube ich auch die große
Enttäuschung in der Partei selbst dass
er nicht ordentlich in Anführungszeichen
sequenziert hat wann er gerade das
Gewicht eines Präsidenten wirklich in
die Waagschale wirft um da entsprechend
auch den das Blatt umzuwenden aber und
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen alles was
ein Joe Biden macht findet in einem
Medienumfeld statt was tiefgespalten ist
und da finden wir zum Beispiel auch noch
den Fox News Sender der weiterhin auf
der Seite von von Vladimir Putin ist und
nicht vom eigenen Präsidenten
ja wenn wir jetzt mal ansehen das ist ja
eine ganz unheilige Allianz in den USA
gibt gegen den Präsidenten das nennt man
ja Friendly Fire da kommen von vorne
nicht nur die trampisten sondern von
hinten einerseits wir haben schon
angesprochen die ultrakonservativen
unter den Demokraten und dann auf der
anderen Seite die ganz linken unter den
Demokraten die den Präsidenten dann in
verschiedenen politischen Fragen bewusst
oder unbewusst aber schachmatt setzen
wie kommt er da wieder raus er hat ja
eigentlich im Prinzip nur Gegner ja er
hat eine sehr schwierige innenpolitische
Lage er ist angetreten mit dem großen
Versprechen das Land wieder
zusammenzuführen die große Polarisierung
im Land aufzuheben zu heilen zu
versöhnen und ich glaube man kann jetzt
nach einem Jahr sagen dass ihm das nicht
gelungen ist sondern dass die Spaltung
in den USA tiefer gehen als zuvor und
ich glaube das ist auch ein großes
Problem bei der Durchsetzung seiner
Vorhaben weil es eben nicht so ist dass
er eine republikanische Partei hat wie
sie früher einmal war wo man auch
überparteilich in manchen Dingen
zumindest zusammenarbeiten konnte er hat
das geschafft beim Infrastrukturprogramm
aber die Republikaner die da mitgemacht
haben werden ja inzwischen abgestraft
dafür dass sie mitgemacht haben und ich
glaube einfach dass ja dass die Stimmung
im Land so aufgeheizt ist dass es
wahnsinnig schwierig ist für ihn auch
große überparteiliche Projekte wo er die
Republikaner braucht durchzudrücken dazu
kommt dass er am Anfang auch die linke
Seite der Demokraten auf seiner Seite
hatte Bernie Sanders hat ihn ja auch
unterstützt und gelobt und dass die auch
zunehmend enttäuscht ist von dem was Joe
Biden liefern kann ich bin dabei Katrin
klüvereschburg dass er glaube ich
einfach auch zu viel wollte und er muss
zu viele Interessen bedienen Ines Pool
kann man sagen ins aus Sicht von Joe
Biden wer solche Freunde hat die eigene
Partei betrachtet der braucht eigentlich
keine politischen Gegner mehr ist die
politische Klasse in den USA gerade
dabei sich selbst zu demontieren
zur beiden war ganz bestimmt der
richtige Mann um Donald Trump zu
besiegen und vielleicht der einzige
Demokrat und deshalb musste er auch im
Wahlkampf die Versprechung machen die er
gemacht hat er musste auch die Hand
reichen in den linken sowie in den
rechten Flügel ich glaube da müssen wir
jetzt auch einfach fair bleiben
alle wollten alle Demokraten wollten und
weite Teile Europas wollten dass er
Donald Trump ablöst und es war ihm nur
möglich indem er eben die Stimmen aus
allen Lagern der Demokratischen Partei
und auch von manchen republikanerinnen
und Republikanern bekommt ich glaube da
müssen wir einfach ein bisschen fair
bleiben in der
Bewertung der Vergangenheit
ja er hat große Probleme in der eigenen
Partei das ist richtig das ist hier
analysiert worden aber ich möchte doch
auch noch mal wirklich ein Licht darauf
werfen wie die republikanische
Parteipolitik betreibt das ist auch
gestern in der
Pressekonferenz angesprochen worden die
Republikaner versuchen alles um Erfolge
von der Joe Biden zu verhindern sie sind
ganz groß im nein sagen im ablehnen im
verdammen und es ist kaum was zu hören
was sie wirklich positiv vorantreiben
wollen und das ist ein riesiges Problem
für Joe Biden im Moment und es wird ein
großes Problem bleiben vor allem
Nachfolger die von den Demokraten ins
weiß ins Weiße Haus geschickt werden
sozusagen weil es ist seit mehreren
Jahren die Strategie der
republikanischen Partei und die ist
unter Donald Trump sozusagen noch mal
ins Extreme weitergeführt worden wie
soll man in dem Land in dem es nur zwei
Parteien gibt wo sozusagen Kompromisse
zwingend notwendig sind um überhaupt
Politik machen zu können Politik
betreiben können wenn eine Seite
grundsätzlich alles oder fast alles
ablehnt jetzt ist ja sind die
Republikaner werden sich ja sich auch
als Oppositionspartei fühlen vielleicht
kann man da auch nicht so sehr viel
erwarten die Frage ist ja inwieweit eben
gerade die eigene Partei die
demokratische das war ja der Sinn meiner
Frage gerade der linke Flügel ungeduldig
ist mit offenbar nichts zufrieden und
möglicherweise damit auch die
Wahlchancen jetzt im Herbst und auch
dann bei der Präsidentschaftswahl 2024
für die Demokraten erheblich vermindert
obwohl
ja es ist richtig aber wir haben das
auch angesprochen das ist eine
amerikanische big ten Partei also ist
eine Sammelpartei noch mal weil hier
gibt es eben nur zwei Parteien es wurde
gesagt es ist die CDU und die SPD das
ist aber die CDU die SPD die Linken
bisschen FDP bisschen FDP und natürlich
auch die Grüne Partei die sind alle
sozusagen in dieser einen großen Partei
jetzt hat Joe Weiden eine Mehrheit eine
hauchdünne Mehrheit die sozusagen nur in
der Vizepräsidentin besteht und es war
auch schon immer so in der Vergangenheit
dass ein zwei drei oder vier Demokraten
bei verschiedenen Projekten abgesprungen
sind aber das ist nichts Neues also das
ist das sahen wir auch in der
Vergangenheit so neu ist aber nochmal
das möchte ich wirklich noch mal betonen
die Tatsache dass es bei den
Republikanern im Moment kaum jemanden
gibt der den Mut beweist mit den
Demokraten zu bestimmen weil befürchtet
wird dass man dann das Schicksal
erleidet wie zum Beispiel ist Jenny
nämlich von Donald Trump verdammt zu
werden und damit jeglicher
Zukunftschancen beraubt zu werden also
die Probleme liegen nicht primär darin
dass Joe Biden nicht ein zwei drei
Senatoren auf seine Seite ziehen kann
sondern dass die Republikaner wirklich
alles blockieren
ein großer Vorwurf an jeder Republikaner
ist ja wie sie nach Meinung der
Demokraten das Wahlrecht manipulieren
jetzt gilt in den USA ja anders als bei
uns nicht das Prinzip one man oder one
woman one vote also ein Mann eine Frau
eine Stimme sondern ist das Wahlrecht
ist sehr Vertrag das kann durchaus
passieren dass endlich auch wie im
Vereinigten Königreich jemand die Wahl
gewinnt der aber weniger Stimmen hat das
ist das komplizierte Wahlrecht jetzt
wird den Republikanern ja vorgeworfen da
gäbe es schmutzige Tricks wie man das
manipulieren könnte dass möglicherweise
potenzielle Wähler der Demokraten also
vor allen Dingen colored people nicht
zur Wahl gehen was läuft da eigentlich
im Moment gerade ab der Präsident und
die Vizepräsidentin haben sich da ja
jetzt eingeschaltet das gibt eine
richtige Kampagne jetzt auch von
zweiten und von Camilla Harris gegen
diese wahlrechtsbestrebungen der
Republikaner in den einzelnen
Bundesstaaten geht es in den USA nicht
mehr fair zu
nein gerade diese Kampagne lässt dir
zeigen dass es auch nicht gerade
persönliche Worte von Joe Bytes sind
dass sie die anschuldig und ich da
ließen Reden kommen sind schon ziemlich
aggressiv und intensiv muss man sagen
hier geht es prinzipiell darum ob man
auch Bundesebene diese Sache klären
möchte oder es auf lokale und und in den
Ländern selbst Ebene unterschiedlicher
Wahlrechte gelten dürfen und können es
läuft natürlich auch die Gefahr wenn man
das auf Bundesebene konzentriert dass
man hier sehr viel Macht in einer
Thematik versammelt die man vielleicht
verstreut durch die USA mehr
demokratische vielleicht Jackson bei uns
ist garantieren könnte also da gibt es
einfach meinungsunterschiedenheiten es
geht darum ob man jetzt zehn Tage oder
15 Tage vor der Wahl ein absolute ein
schicken darf es geht darum ob man einen
Ausweis zeigen muss da geht's hier um
Wahlprozedere aber ich denke nicht dass
man durch vielleicht unterschiedliche
lenkungsweise hier daran sägt die
Demokratie abzuschaffen also es ist für
mich da kommt jetzt gleich aus
gesagt hat über die republikanische
Pokale Politik erstens gab es gerade ein
großes Paket daher
halbleiterinvestitionen wo Dutzende von
republikanische Abgeordneten Senatoren
zugestimmt haben warum weil die
Demokraten auf die Republikaner
zugegangen sind eingegangen sind es ist
nicht neu dass eine Oppositionspolitik
oder Oppositionspartei
Oppositionspolitik betreibt ich war
damals im Weißen Haus mit tolstadt kann
mich gut erinnern wie Barack Obama und
Harry Wii damals führende Demokraten ein
migrationsgesetz verweigert hat was ist
ein Wahlkampf gebraucht haben also ich
glaube nicht dass man sagen kann die
eine Seite blockiert die andere macht
das Gut den enzy prce
liest ist sie plötzlich gefeiert in ganz
Europa und für mich keiner sich etwas
widersetzt an dieser plötzlich der böse
blockadepolitiker ich denke das ist
nicht gerade mal eine faire Sichtweise
Führerin und den minderheitsführer im
Kongress man muss ja auch fairerweise
noch dazu sagen dass Infrastruktur da
haben wir glaube ich ungefähr drei
Dutzend republikanische Abgeordnete
mitgestimmt aber wir sind noch beim
Wahlrecht dann schiebe ich jetzt gleich
die Frage nach an Sie weiter ist Donald
Trump mit diesen Aktivitäten zum
Wahlrecht dabei die Demokratien in den
USA sturmreif zu schießen ganz klares ja
ganz klares Ja in 39 Bundesstaaten
werden 440 verschiedene wahlprovisorien
geändert und zwar durch sowohl politisch
wie juristische Methoden das macht diese
republikanische Partei strategisch also
das ist das ist Kampf auf Ansage ich
glaube die Brisanz mit denen das den
Republik mit denen das den Demokraten um
die Ohren geflogen ist war vielleicht
nicht so deutlich am Anfang abzusehen
aber dass das zu einer Takt in taktisch
verbundenen Strategie erkoren ist ist
nämlich genau das wir sehen die Kopplung
des obstruktionismus innerhalb und dass
da das ein oder Gesetz ein oder andere
Gesetz mal durchkommen kann ist eine
Sache aber insgesamt ist Obstruktion die
Politik und wenn das nicht geht dann
wird die Demokratie ausgehöhlt in den
USA und das aus Machtgier denn es ergibt
auch die andere Version und die hat
Peter hau angesprochen das war die
republikanische Partei von George W bush
der genau sich angeschaut hat wie
demografisch das Land sich entwickelt
und gesagt hat wir müssen die
republikanische Partei erweitern
verändern nachhaltiger denken und das
hat der trumpismus das hat der
Populismus eines Donald Trump
ausgeschaltet sondern gesagt wir
manipulieren die Regeln so dass wir so
lange wie es können noch uns macht
zusichern können und das sehen wir und
das ist wirklich in meiner Meinung
Raubbau an der amerikanischen Demokratie
das macht dieses System nicht nachhaltig
ich bin da auch eher bei Frau Klüver
ashbrook ich glaube wir müssen wir
müssen schon vorsichtig sein es gibt
gerade in Deutschland immer so eine
Tendenz wenn man gerade auch Bücher sich
anguckt die über Amerika geschrieben
werden die es hier zu kaufen gibt da
wird immer vom Ende der Demokratie
gesprochen vom beginnenden Bürgerkrieg
von Amerikas Gotteskriegern der radik
Rechten und ich möchte das alles auch
nicht klein machen aber ich glaube man
muss schon schon hinschauen es gibt auch
sehr viel was in den USA funktioniert
demokratisch aber ich Frau
klüvereschburg hat Recht die
Republikaner machen Dinge die ich finde
sehr grenzwertig sind zum Beispiel durch
das jeremandering das ist die der
Zuschnitt der Wahlkreise wenn man
Wahlkreise gezielt so zuschneidet dass
man das Endergebnis für sich sichert
dann ist das für mich grenzwertig
demokratisch oder wenn man den Zugang zu
Wahllokalen beschränkt wenn man zum
Beispiel plötzlich Wahllokale in
Regionen dicht macht wo besonders viele
Minderheiten wohnen schwarze zum
Beispiel und plötzlich ist da kein
Wahllokal mehr oder es gibt nur eines
und man muss acht Stunden anstehen um zu
wählen oder wenn man die Barrieren um
zur Wahl zu gehen erhöht indem man nicht
nur einen Ausweis sondern sich mehrfach
quasi legitimieren muss dass man wählen
darf all das sind Barrieren die gezielt
Menschen ausschließen zur Wahl zu gehen
und ich finde das schwierig und das muss
man schon so ansprechen das glaube ich
muss Herr Rau auch zu erkennen
wenn ich bin ich bin da völlig bei dir
das Jeremy ein riesen Problem ist in den
USA und man sollte nicht zu tun als ob
es die Republikaner sind diese Strategie
betreiben und die Demokraten nicht die
Republikaner haben viel mit Jeremy
gespielt das ist das schnellste
unterschiedlichen Wahlbezirke aber dort
wo die Demokraten regieren wie zum
Beispiel in Roman sind passiert das
ganze das gleiche und da möchte ich
einfach die Gleichstellung hier nicht
nicht in Kauf nehmen dass wir die eine
Partei sozusagen das Gute betreiben die
andere das Böse nur weil Job eigentlich
durchkommt mit seinem Programm das wird
die Republikaner nicht besprochen und
abgestimmt worden ist bedeutet es nicht
dass die Republikaner die einzige Partei
der Geschichte der USA sind in der
jüngeren Geschichte die hier blockieren
also das gleiche habe ich auch schon
eine persönlich in einer
republikanischen Administration und wir
denken hier in Deutschland dass wir ein
besonderes
hier kurz reinspringen darf ich glaube
wir müssen hier einfach auf die Zahlen
gucken klar es ist schon immer wieder
versucht worden aber in diesem Ausmaß
wird es die republikanische Partei
derzeit versucht in so vielen Bezirken
und Bundesstaaten in wichtigen
Bundesstaaten ist es nicht nur meiner
Meinung nach grenzwertig sondern das ist
wirklich Demokratie gefährdend und Herr
Rau da müssen wir jetzt schon finde ich
ein bisschen in den richtigen
Dimensionen unterwegs sein und können
dann da nicht Äpfel mit Birnen
vergleichen in diesem Ausmaß mit den
Konsequenzen würde es die Demokratie des
demokratische System hier in den
Vereinigten Staaten aushebeln und wenn
ich da noch ganz kurz in die
unterstützende Frau Pohl in die Seite
springen darf wenn es hier um die
Demokratie ginge dann hätten wir einen
überparteiliches und außen nach außen
gelagertes Gremium um sich die
Ereignisse des 6 Januars anzugucken und
nicht ein gerade mal so zusammengefügtes
ermittlungsermittlungsausschuss
innerhalb des Kongresses wo nur zwei
Republikaner teilnehmen wenn es wirklich
den Republikanern um den Abstand der
amerikanischen Demokratie ginge
losgelöst vom Parteibuch dann sehen
solche Fragen nach den Ursprüngen und
den Auswirkungen des 6 Januars ganz
anders aus gut und wir denken in
Deutschland immer wir hätten einen
besonders problematisches Wahlrecht das
ja auch zu Diskussionen anders gibt wir
wollen uns mal wieder andere politische
Beteiligte vorknöpfen Ines Pool und zwar
die linken Demokraten noch mal es ist ja
noch ein sogenanntes Sozial- und
Klimapaket unterwegs im Parlament daraus
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts werden
unter Umständen auch wegen der alles
oder nichtshaltung linker Demokraten ist
das ein Problem auch dass man zu viel
auf einmal will und dann am Schluss mit
leeren Händen da steht gerade in der für
beiden und die Demokraten so wichtigen
Sozial- und Klimapolitik
ja Bild back better war der Name dieses
Programms in der Tat hat Joe Biden
wirklich versucht in seinem ersten Jahr
alles durchzudrücken was geht weil er
sich natürlich der Wahrscheinlichkeit
gewahr ist dass er in den mütterns also
am 9 November oder 8 November jetzt hier
diesen Jahres die Mehrheiten verlieren
kann oder sehr wahrscheinlich verliert
in den Häusern und dadurch noch viel
schwieriger wird regieren können
deswegen hat er so viel auf den Tisch
gelegt der hat gestern angedeutet dass
er durchaus jetzt bereit ist dieses
Paket aufzuschnüren um einzelne einzelne
Elemente durchzubekommen zum Beispiel
Steuererleichterung für Familien mit
Kindern und auch in beim Thema
Immigration die eine oder andere Sache
und es ist ganz wichtig für allen Dingen
für die DemokratInnen und Demokraten die
zu Wiederwahl stehen weil die müssen
einfach was vorweisen können was die
US-amerikanische Bevölkerung sofort
spürt wir haben das schon angesprochen
bei dem infrastrukturpaket wird es mit
den lange dauern bis man da irgendwelche
positiven Auswirkungen verspürt aber
wenn die eine oder andere
soziale Gesetzgebung jetzt doch noch
durchkommt in den kommenden Monaten und
da haben auch durchaus die die bisher
Querulanten sage ich mal innerhalb der
Demokratischen Partei die Bereitschaft
gezeigt dann hat er doch ein bisschen
was auf der Habenseite zu verzeichnen
deswegen glaube ich dass er das auch tun
wird also dieses große Paket aufschnürt
und dann einzelne Teile davon zur
Abstimmung vielleicht auch sagen dass
das vielleicht demokratischen Kandidaten
in Kalifornien und Ergon helfen wird
aber nicht vielleicht in Florida oder in
Alabama wir sollten vielleicht noch
einen Blick zu einem anderen politischen
Bereich wenden der für uns ja besonders
wichtig ist man hat ja geglaubt mit dem
Amtsantritt von Joe Biden könnten die
transatlantischen Beziehungen wieder
belebt werden
dass sie diese Gefahr die man gesehen
hat die USA wenden sich von Europa
ablassen uns links oder rechts liegen wo
auch immer
hat sich diese Hoffnung bewahrheitet
oder ist da vielleicht doch so eine
gewisse Fortsetzung der Trump schon
Politik auch zu erkennen ich hatte das
angesprochen zu Anfang gab es eben den
Honeymoon die positive Phase wo wir
dachten ja es ist oder wo viele dachten
ich glaube zu Unrecht in Europa die
Amerikaners ist wieder so wie früher wie
unter Obama oder noch früher und ich
glaube das ist eben ein Irrtum und ich
glaube das ist das was die Europäer
realisieren müssen dass es kein
zurückgeben wird die Vereinigten Staaten
haben sich verändert und Joe Biden ist
der dritte Präsident wenn man es mal
anschaut in einer Reihe von Obama über
Trump bis jetzt beiden der sagt unser
Fokus liegt in Asien wir unsere
Priorität ist China und Europa ihr müsst
als Europäer langsam in die Lage kommen
selber für eure Sicherheit zu sorgen
oder zumindest einen gleichwertigen
Beitrag zu leisten ihr könnt euch nicht
länger auf uns blind verlassen ihr müsst
aufhören mit dem Trittbrett fahren und
ich glaube dass wir das ganz klar
gesehen haben eben gerade auch in der
Entscheidung dieses dieses u-boot-deals
den ich vorhin angesprochen habe der ja
wo es ja um den indopazifischen Raum
geht und wo wir eben sehen das ist die
Priorität trotzdem finde ich gibt es
ganz positive Signale unter dieser
Administration die Rückkehr in
internationale Organisationen den Willen
mit uns in diesen Organisationen
zusammenzuarbeiten und ich finde jetzt
gerade ganz aktuell in der russlandfrage
sieht man eine wahnsinnige
pendel-diplomatie heute Anthony blinken
in Berlin ich höre das wirklich auch
sehr stark von deutscher Seite aus
Regierungskreisen wie sehr man auch
zufrieden ist mit dem Grad der
Einbindung und ich glaube dass die
Amerikaner ein Stück weit aus dieser
Erfahrung Afghanistan und orkes gelernt
haben und wirklich investieren in dieses
Verhältnis gerade ich frage mich
momentan eher ob wir bereit sind auch
entsprechend in dieses Verhältnis zu
investieren
in Sachen Ukraine angesprochen haben
könnte man ja das war auch zu lesen dass
möglicherweise das Thema oder der Fall
Ukraine die letzte Mission der USA in
Europa ist oder für den europäischen
Kontinent ist an dieser sehr wohl eine
Befürchtung sondern der Befürchtung was
dran ich habe so ähnliche argumentiert
in einem Stück was es heute in der Welt
erscheint oder erschienen ist ich habe
gesagt die Europäer müssen jetzt sehr
genau auf den Kalender schauen denn die
Frage ist genau wie Frau poliering das
angesprochen hat was war denn jetzt der
Irrtum oder die apparation wenn wirklich
der Fokus auf China sein soll und wird
und ein Präsident 2024 ein Republikaner
ist wenn es Donald Trump ist ist er ein
ein NATO verachtender Präsident der am
liebsten die Truppen
amerikanischer die amerikanischen
Truppen gerne wieder abziehen wollen
würde der NATO das Vertrauen entziehen
würde und dann wäre die Frage wäre
Amerika Amerika dann noch eine
Demokratie nach Artikel 2 des
NATO-Vertrages das sind alles Fragen die
im Raum stehen das heißt die Europäer
müssen Nacharbeiten aber das sie eben
schon nach lange seit langer Zeit und
jetzt tickt die Uhr denn wenn diese
Situation wie sie jetzt haben in eine
trump-präsidentschaft gekommen wäre dann
hätten wir vielleicht nicht dieses die
besondere diplomatische Ballett was wir
heute in Berlin gesehen haben Europäer
diese Gefahr erkannt ist das den
maßgeblichen Politikerinnen und
Politikern in Europa bewusst
unzureichend noch aber es wird sehr
schwer wir müssten sehr viel
Steuergelder in die Hand genommen werden
und es müsste sehr viel für die
öffentliches öffentliche Klima und das
Verständnis getan werden und deswegen
haben wir heute in der Rede von Toni
blinken gesehen dass er im Grunde
genommen die Anklageschrift gegenüber
Russland vorgetragen hat und die hat er
nicht getan um die Politiker im Raum zu
beschwichtigen sondern Argumente
gegenüber dem deutschen Wheeler zu
machen rau hat die amerikanische
Gesellschaft ich meine nicht nur die
politische Klasse ich meine die
amerikanische Gesellschaft überhaupt
noch Bock auf Europa der vorher viele
Präsident Donald Trump der war ganz im
Golfspiel in Schottland
Boris Johnson von der glaube ich auch
noch ganz gut aber ansonsten hat er an
Europa eigentlich kein gutes Haar
gelassen ist das eine Entwicklung die
sich fortsetzen wird dass ich die USA
jetzt nicht nur geopolitisch sondern
auch so gefühlsmäßig von Europa abwendet
naja nichtsdestotrotz wenn man den
amerikanischen Diplomaten oder auch
Gesellschaft pflegt wer sind unsere
Ängsten Verbündete würde man immer sagen
die ersten Ansprechpartner sind laut in
Paris Berlin Brüssel muss man auch
hinzufügen am Europa ist eben uns sehr
eng verbunden sind quasi ein
europäisches gründungsland könnte man
sagen und obwohl jetzt das Gewicht
internationalen Beziehungen
Wirtschaftsmacht unter anderem sich
Richtung Asien bewegt gibt es ja den
Begriff Eurasien nicht und Europa ist
hier wirklich Schlüssel Kontinent das
ist für uns die Ängste Partnerschaft das
ist der Startpunkt und wirklich in eurer
Aktien eine Position zu halten es ist
für uns auch Einflussgebiet so dass man
in Afrika in Nahen Osten unter anderem
macht projizieren kann und natürlich die
wirtschaftliche Macht Europas das
Gewicht ist für viele relevanten Fragen
einfach essentiell zusammen sind wir ein
Hälfte ungefähr das internationalen
Bruttoinlandsproduktes und kann man
gegenüber zum Beispiel Peking und China
wirklich eine harte Position einnehmen
und diese auch durchsetzen ich glaube
das ist man sich bewusst auch wenn man
versteht dass wir weg von der Ära da
reinen Globalisierung Richtung eine
Machtkampf mit revisionistischen Mächten
insbesondere im Oscar und Peking und
hinbewegen jetzt wollen wir hier nicht
nur im nebelstochern wir haben ja schon
auf diese Pressekonferenz von Joe Biden
einjähriges Amtsjubiläum hingewiesen da
hat er folgendes gesagt zum nicht nur
zum transatlantischen Verhältnis sondern
zu seinem Verhalten gegenüber der
Ukraine und einer möglichen russischen
Invasion dort
Russland wird zur Verantwortung gezogen
werden im Falle eines Einmarsches das
kommt natürlich darauf an was passiert
wenn es ein kleinerer Übergriff ist da
muss man noch mal genauer hinschauen
aber wenn Sie das umsetzen was sie mit
der bereits gebündelten Militärmacht
umsetzen können dann wird das eine
Katastrophe für Russland wenn Sie eine
Invasion in der Ukraine durchführen dann
werden wir dafür sorgen dass Russland
und die russische Wirtschaft sehr zu
leiden haben
Ines Pohl also ein kleinerer Übergriff
hat kleinere Sanktionen zur Folge ein
mittelschwerer Übergriff mittelschwere
Fraktion und ein schwerer Übergriff
schweres Sanktionen was wollte uns
jobeiten damit sagen muss man vielleicht
jetzt noch dazu sagen dass Weiße Haus
hat diese Äußerung ja etwas korrigiert
und gesagt Sanktion ist Sanktionen
ich glaube Joe Biden hat die Wahrheit
versprochen und hätte das aber sicher
nicht tun sollen hätte er auf seine
Beraterinnen und Berater gehört machen
uns nichts vor wenn wir die
amerikanische Bevölkerung befragen wie
sich die USA gegenüber eine möglichen in
eines möglichen Einmarsches von Russland
in die Ukraine verhalten sollten würden
wir auf ganz große staunende Augen
treffen die überhaupt nicht wissen wo
die Ukraine überhaupt liegt das spielt
bei der oberwiegenden Mehrheit dieses
Landes einfach nicht oder kaum eine
Rolle auch der Kalte Krieg ist lang
vorbei Russland ist nicht mehr die
primäre Bedrohung wenn man
Amerikanerinnen Amerikaner die sich für
Außenpolitik überhaupt interessieren
fragt dann kommt mal schnell zu China
als einem sozusagen einer
wirtschaftlichen und politischen
Bedrohung dann vielleicht noch zum Iran
aber Russland steht da nicht mehr so
weit oben auf der
aufmerksamkeitsskala deswegen ist es
glaube ich einfach ehrlich gewesen was
nur gesagt hat dass die USA damit großer
Zurückhaltung regieren würden wenn Putin
sich nur die eine oder andere sozusagen
Region schnappt aber natürlich kann man
das nach außen nicht vertreten und
deswegen hat es Weiße Haus da heute
massiv
zurückgerudert auch Stoltenberg hat sich
dazu geäußert das war natürlich ein
großer Schreck auch innerhalb der
Ukraine gestern als beiden das gesagt
hat aber es ist sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass es überhaupt
irgendwelche militärischen Aktionen
seitens der USA gibt auch das wird ja
immer wieder in Deutschland diskutiert
und wie weit die wirtschaftlichen
Sanktionen dann am Ende wirklich gehen
würden ich auch glaube auch da müssen
wir mit großer Vorsicht hingucken ich
glaube zum Beispiel nicht das ist
wirklich passieren wird dass Russland
aus dem Swift-Abkommen rausgenommen wird
was wirklich weh tun würde eben auch
innerhalb der USA dazu wäre nämlich die
Bevölkerung dieses Landes einfach nicht
bereit was hier ein deutscher Politiker
auch als Atombombe auf den Finanzmärkten
habe ich das als Wortmeldung gerade von
ihnen
ich habe nur sagen mitgedacht weil sie
das gerade von Friedrich merzer wie in
einem mir erklären an den Russen gerade
was wir nicht Unternehmen werden anstatt
eine Abschreckungspolitik durchzuführen
dass etwas anbetuität und Stärke
Russland vorweist damit man Putin sein
kann es gibt ja bestimmte Grenzen und
muss nicht unbedingt wissen was
geschieht wenn man diese Grenzen
überquert darüber hinaus ist die
amerikanische Strategie überwiegend von
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen geprägt
nicht ausreichend aus meiner Sicht von
militärischen Maßnahmen so stark das
Potenzial mal überlegen muss wenn er
einmarschiert dass es so gehen wird wie
er sich als vorstellt nur noch zwei
Minuten Zeit vielleicht an Sie weiter
hier im Studio noch die Frage wie kommt
Joe Biden eigentlich aus dieser
Situation jetzt wieder raus es muss
jetzt irgendetwas passieren vielleicht
hat er ja die Kongresswahlen schon
verloren gegeben aber er möchte ja
entweder wiedergewählt werden oder die
Demokraten möchten das Präsidentenamt be
zweite Amtszeit für beiden zweite oder
zweite Amtszeit für Trump was muss
beiden jetzt tun also ich glaube schon
das was er gesagt hat gestern der
Pressekonferenz muss auch passieren er
muss das was er noch umsetzen kann
umsetzen und zwar beherzt und da muss er
selber in die Bresche springen selber
mehr verhandeln er hat gestern zugegeben
er muss auch mehr mit miltronomie Reden
und er muss ins Land gehen die Leute
müssen ihn wahrnehmen können
einigermaßen
verhandlungsfähig ist oder
kooperationsfähig was meinen Sie was was
ist für was wo Spalten jetzt den
Ansatzpunkt finden denn
Turnaround er muss auch schaffen wieder
stark zu erscheinen und Führung zu
zeigen ich glaube das ist das was vielen
Amerikanern gefehlt hat eben diese diese
Führung sie haben gedacht das Weiße Haus
ist im Prinzip verweist es gab wenige
Pressekonferenzen und er muss mit ein
paar Themen Punkten er muss Akzente
setzen und er muss klare Kante zeigen
und er muss da sein er muss präsent sein
jetzt will auch viel auf Reisen gehen
hat er ja gesagt und sich mehr kümmern
also hat er sich zu wenig lieber zu sehr
in seinem Amtssitz sitzen na ich glaube
machen wir uns nichts vor ich glaube ein
Problem was er einfach hat ist dass er
tatsächlich in den letzten Jahren massiv
gealtert ist und von vielen Wählerinnen
und Wählern einfach auch so wahrgenommen
wird daher kommt auch die Schwäche das
ist bedauerlich aber ich glaube das
lässt sich nicht ändern
gut wir werden sehen was aus der Politik
in den USA wird was in der Ukraine
passiert was mit den transatlantischen
Verhältnis passiert ich bedanke mich bei
Katrin klüvereschbruck bei Jana
bei Ines Pohl und bei Peter Roll beide
zugeschaltet aus Washington liebe
Zuschauer am Sonntag der internationale
Frühschoppen um 12 Uhr mit Eva Lindenau
und dem Thema Preisschock zum
Jahresauftakt was erwartet uns 2022
jetzt folgt Phoenix der Tag mit
Konstanzer platzke und da bleiben wir
beim Thema denn der US-Außenminister hat
heute Berlin besucht war bei seiner
neuen Amtskollegin Annalena baerbock ein
Schwerpunkt von Phoenix der Tag bleiben
Sie bei uns
[Musik]